leute jetzt ich habe euch noch
versprochen dass ich verrate was es ist
was ich wieder zugelegt habe und zwar
habe ich mir folgendes neu zugelegten
service escape sonderlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute eine
runde jump league auf mtv.com
und ich komme ich mal drei blöcke weit
weg email ja das studium ist wieder
losgegangen ihr seht auch ich habe
wieder meinen face com rahmen drin und
nicht mit dem von max bin ich bei ihm
hatte als er in seinem pc war
ich bin jetzt wieder mein pc in dem
wieder an spartacus auf dem alten
homeboy die idee noch kennen der als ja
jetzt lange lange lange nicht in
erscheinung getreten
das setup hier ist noch wieder bis
hinten es ist anders natürlich als als
bei meiner familie zu hause aber es ist
auch gut gut zwar nicht schön aber es
ist gut und ich muss jetzt irgendwie
selbstgewissen reinfinden
ich habe auch heute eine sache die ich
na ja die mich sehr lange begleitet hat
einen gegenstand der mich sehr lang
begleitet hat habe ich heute abgelegt
und hab mir ab ihn ersetzt durch einen
neueren hat was es ist das kann ich am
ende verraten
als allererstes müssen mal gucken dass
wir hier bisschen ich diese runde durch
kaum habe zumindest meine steinachs
goldhelm sehr schön wunderbar gg
es sieht alles ein bisschen anders aus
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich vielen
auffallen die jetzt das anderes setup
gewohnt waren jetzt das mikro mehr in
der facetime drin
es ist alles noch nicht noch nicht
wieder so auf 100 prozentig perfektem
niveau eingestellt
ich muss auch noch mit allem einfach
alles alles komplett muss wieder richtig
hingebogen werden ist momentan noch
nicht so weit aber das kriegen wir
wieder hin
vornehmlich auf mega produktiv bin ich
bin einfach gestern abend angekommen
habe schon so viele sinnvolle sachen
gemacht ich bin echt erstaunt so bin ich
normalerweise nicht unbedingt
normalerweise spiele ich erstmal aber
heute de wie produktiv ich bin erst
früher aufgestanden habe morgens haster
weg was ich erledigen wollte ich hab
gewaschen ich habe eingekauft ich habe
müll rausgebracht das ist richtig
richtig crazy ist einfach krass so ich
weiß nicht warum aber ich bin als
anderer mensch ich wieder meine wg
zurückgekehrt muss man sagen es ist
wirklich es ist wirklich eine lustige
sache keine ahnung woher es kam nicht
geschafft ich hab jetzt halt auch
komplett anders equipment also ich habe
wieder die andere tastatur in andere
maus oder nicht auf jeden fall muss mich
erstmal wieder bisschen einspielen
deswegen werde ich jetzt auch von julius
2000 vom safe ipo können wir darüber
wurde schon sagen wo kommt da jetzt hier
nicht verpacken
ok nice läuft soweit sehr schön so ich
muss auch noch ich muss alle mischen
alles wieder komplett neue reinfinden
ich glaube auch dass ich mir nachts
neben der anschaffung die ich heute
gemacht habe dann auch demnächst mal
neues micro holen werde
notgedrungen wahrscheinlich nicht diesen
monat also wenn ich diesen worten ich im
lotto gewinne dann kann ich mir auf dem
fall kein mikro holen ich weiß nicht
vielleicht gewinnt ich antworte wäre
nice oder einer von euch gewinnt im
lotto und spendiert mir den betrag für
ordentliches micro geschafft und ich
fahr runter junge es gibt es gibt echt
nicht leute es ist es bitter es ist
einfach bitter
meine fresse na gut ich werde jetzt
nicht zu lange auf die folter spannen
und will schon mal für diejenigen die
jetzt noch dran sind verkündet was denn
der neue gegenstand ist nicht mehr
zugelegt habe und zwar ist das eine neue
maus manche haben es vielleicht geahnt
die ganz ganz fleißig auf twitter vor
nicht ein bisschen über meinem
ausgelastet auf twitter habe jetzt
einfach die ganze zeit den ganzen januar
über mit maxis maus gespielt mit der
roccat kone und habe jetzt mir gedacht
okay du bist mit deiner razer imperator
überhaupt nicht zufrieden
dann musste ändern habe ich die kohle
für den raum auszukaufen natürlich nicht
wahrscheinlich werde ich wieder hungern
müssen diesen monat aber ist auch kein
ding nicht passt so dramatisch ist nicht
alles geht schon
ich gehe halt einmal nicht feiern oder
so ist halt so als stammpersonal schauen
dass man irgendwie vorrat unruhe zu
recht konnten gesprungen der ist der
sieht so scheiße außen aber irgendwie
klappt er jedes mal richtig froh jetzt
und heute an gibt es übrigens wieder ins
team leute 8 uhr okay ist die windows
per insight ist durchaus fahrt habe ich
muss mich jetzt halt auch dann wenn
diese andere tastatur gewöhnen müssen so
verschieden wie tastaturen sein können
max jetzt immer diese also maxi die
roccat rocky trice oder dieser letzten
sprung man es ist so klicke ich immer
das gefühl
dass sich einfach
bei diesem sprung der war viel cooler
als der vor kurzem als die dauer zu zwei
scheiben gemacht haben so wie hier sah
dass daraus und nicht nur eine
bei einer ist nämlich schwierig ok
geschafft das ist so einer meiner angst
sprünge hier dieser letzte sprung war
von dem von der uno pen serie
bis dahin geht es je nach tagesform auch
geht es auch mal nicht
aber dieser dieser letzte sprung ist
einfach so absolutes no go heute haben
wir das spiel heute 8 uhr mit meiner
internetseite mir geht aber trotzdem
flüssig würde ich sagen und noch habe
ich übrigens zeit noch habe ich die zeit
des semesters nicht richtig losgelegt
deswegen kann ich mir das noch mal
erlauben armee zu streamen das heißt
noch habe ich die zeit
ich kann mir die zeit auch unterm
semester nehmen wir werden wie werden
wir sehen wie es geht wären einfach
schauen müssen wie ich zeit habe und
wenn ich zeit habe werde ich sicher auch
mal so zu 80 und 90 prozent
dann in binz teams investieren abends
ich hab da irgendwie kein problem damit
sich gegeben mega gerne feiern also
wirklich gerne aber ich habe auch kein
problem damit zu sagen okay gut heute
mal nicht heute die ich halt nicht
feiern weil ich mir jetzt in denen neue
computermaus gekauft habe oder weil ich
mein auto tanken musste so ich finde es
endlich ganz cool das mal so ein
bisschen hauszuhalten
also ist es mal cool jetzt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt so als student mit ist ein
ganzes leben noch machen muss natürlich
auch durch polen
ich habe ich sehr wohl gesehen du
kleiner judas website
natürlich war das ein spaß ist aber ist
dass man hier bis ins wasser ausgeben so
der ley
wir haben nicht so dass post equipment
obwohl die runde beendet haben habe ich
papa wichtigsten übersehen die
kommentare rein
ich hätte nicht mal so auf ok drauf als
du bist du bist das mal dauern
so gibt brot oder nice gibt compass als
andenken kommt was es so was wie das
skype früheren treffen unter den
indianern das benutzt man heutzutage auf
jump league nimmt den kompass mit
welchem mann getötet habt und wenn
jemand sagt ihr seid kann kein richtiger
mann und zeigt ihm die compass erwirken
ergattert hat in eurem leben und ich ein
bisschen aufs dach drauf und er fiel
wieder unter pech gehabt
bitter aber gut so markant mittlerweile
die alte daraus schöpfen ging nämlich
eine weile lang nicht dass man die items
daraus gestiftet hat mittlerweile geht
es wieder
und ich muss sagen wollte ich freue mich
richtig auf den leistung heute abend war
ein richtig cooler tag bisher
ich hoffe mal dass mit dieser aufnahme
alles in ordnung ist habe ich das
mikrofon spricht eigentlich alles dafür
dass das passen sollte
oder kommt einer und thorsten frei
bekommen und als ob wir das überlebt wie
hat er das überlebt man paul paul 50-60
warum warum kannst du das überleben
fahrrad mir dein geheimnis wie geht das
hab ich doch recht oft getroffen
seltsam die abstauber schreibt er ja gut
ist aber so im leben es wird immer
wissen abgestaubt so lässt sich hier
noch einer der noch gefressen will ok
doch nicht so das ist dann haben wir
jetzt nicht eliminiert er hatte noch
zwei leben revue so aber hatte den fall
eingeschlossen sehe ich gerade nicht
okay du gehst wird man darauf drauf du
bist nicht bitte mal wirklich bitte mal
dauern also jetzt ganz ehrlich
eine gute ranger auf diesem server
sonnenstrom ist nicht schlecht momentan
jetzt hier noch ein weiteres feuer und
sie hatte der drei leben
ich hätte nur drei leben ich habe mich
auch gerade noch gar nicht aufgefallen
wahrscheinlich hat die ganze zeit
irgendwo verkochen und jetzt geht auf
mich oder wie ja bitte anderer duale
hilf mir lust dass man die scherben
wieder auf du wirst in die geschichte
eingehen als der retter oder konnte olaf
leffler fünfter hinter mir erst die
ganze zeit hinter mir eiskalt
er ist echt permanent twenty four seven
hinter mir aber ich feiere
naja gut daran so schreibt er im chat
das ist natürlich nicht leute jetzt ich
habe mich noch versprochen dass ich
verrate was es ist was ich bin zugelegt
habe und zwar habe ich mir folgendes neu
zugelegt service bereits ist es eine
maus ist aber welche maus ist es das
ließ sich jetzt auf es ist die roccat
die ich mir gegönnt habe da war ich sehr
zufrieden damit wie die bei max performt
hat an seinem pc und hab mir gedacht ich
wollte ja auch mal so jetzt haben das
aufgelöst wie sieht es mit nächste video
wieder das gerne daumen nach oben da
macht's gut